Amy Hubbard asks for blogs just starting
out how do I get people to be
interviewed without being a big-name
media company Amy your question really
means to me which is how do I go out and
get people where I can take their brand
equity as a starting point for mine
right like if I can interview Gary Vee
and put it out there some of his fans
will come over listen to that interview
and then they'll become aware of me so
what you're talking about is equus
equity leveraging arbitrage brilliant
agree with it if you look out and if you
look at pot you know for the people that
are listening if you look at podcast
lane that's how they all do it right
like that's what I did a bunch of those
interviews perming Jab Jab right hook
and then they're leveraging my name over
and over and over again to build
audience so it is a classic game there's
a dirty little secret Amy people that
have leverage and have fame even if you
call it Z level fame like me they like
to talk and so I'm gonna tell you
something that kind of refers to
question number one on this episode
which is the answer is hustle I would
just keep asking I'm asking and asking
I would audit all the places that look
like you or kind of like you and look at
the people that have done interviews
there and when you start realizing that
I and Tim Ferriss and Seth Godin like to
give interviews cuz we also like the
exposure we also have been successful we
like to give back I loved a couple years
ago or last year of my interview 365 day
year thing where I just gave people
interviews that didn't even have any
audience because I was giving back some
don't want to give a video interviews
unless you're big that's why you get
nosed others do it because they like to
pay back to the community and they
remember grinding and the person that
gave them a break and so very honestly I
would ask and oh by the way I got a real
curveball for you and this is for
everybody listening sometimes you need
to ask the same person 11 times and one
could say that you're being annoying but
if you come from a good place and you do
it with a prideful tack and you do it an
appropriate way and if you're actually
listening to what's going on in their
world
maybe Tim's got a new book coming out
maybe he redesigned his website maybe
he's got a new podcast those are times
to strike like a Cobra when they want
something and you want something than
interests a
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe